last summer I was working for a
consultant in Midtown it was an
objectively crappy job you know you're
not the only one I think let me just by
the end of today could you just tell the
front desk that if my mom calls - just
um you know tell her that I stepped out
to lunch or something just for today
until I get a new job I can email you to
let you know what I do you know what you
want to do like with your life this is
David Shapiro I sell weed now David hey
all your conversations to a minimum you
understand me you call me when you need
all right seem nice one night I met a
girl do you wanna dance
you know I don't I don't really dance
that was how I met Kate okay I can't do
this like I think when you touched my
boob that's sort of when I I sort of
drew the line sure sure
[Music]
could you just not sell it and then say
that you did can I also get some of
those baggies please you go to a jeweler
what do you why do you think that that
is what you put in the bag is yeah
that's why I need the bag is this for my
Tori ranked facility yeah oh god sorry
everyone's worried about you because you
sell weed on the Internet
I should probably just got these what
are those I don't know what's going on
with you though are you okay
thank you get the check
separate separate bills I just really
want the best for you I mean I really
care about you every time we hang out I
have to worry that the DEA is gonna show
off the DEA yeah really yeah I don't
know what else to do this is something
that I'm glad
can't be a part-time drug dealer I was a
blueberry hiss then does it have like
blueberry plant DNA like spliced into it
or something no bee
you
you